hello no Morris es el kebir parinama oh
what a menorah Kagome what a maroon
ashram the hazardous energy like a
bizarro Italy our Vienna hokum our faith
hawala LAN LAN world Ito learner
Colombiamoda in us-nato a little wavy
lot it is the moon away no Lauren nah no
how does it smell mahogany one swallow
Antonella fool you are happy if this
treehouse because of you yes T here hand
of yr when I follow an authoritarian
love unit now assalam aleikum Italy that
care to brothers and sisters and their
friends hope you guys doing well and
welcome to this video now
first are the big Europe because few
points I want amazing cleric in net no
way shape or form do I have a
supercilious bombers I must do this to
the bottom so inshallah nella blessing I
don't have the intention that I said
before the good intention etc however
when you try to find the fault of
another person well it may be a squadron
and a whippet maybe if you try to find
their mistakes and try to rock with my
dear probably need to know your place
you need to know your place you are a
brother that you know and I know and
I've met you you are a new student
normally she wasn't practicing one and a
half year ago a key now that you came to
the scene slow down slow down my brother
you know just cause you're studying and
using a few Arabic terms and you've
learned something a key stay in your
lane my brother
don't jump to other wings if you know
the hard shoulder see in the hard
shoulder after here there's another lane
that's for the van and a middle name is
the general Cardon the third n is for
overtaking yeah okay you've not properly
stay in the hard shoulder don't even
move your car stay there
study the knowledge study your religions
to go swing to me we both are ignorant
yeah you know and I know so Brahma stick
to encode each other you wanted
to defend the honor of a believing men
or women is very important
slander is a big thing and if somebody
slammed in someone unjustly to clarify
this this is why I'm doing this video
what they want to clarify well lollie is
Ramadan fasting I'm fasting and I swear
by Allah as far as I know myself
we know this most intention a good
however for actions we accepted the
intention should be good and your action
should be according to the Quran and
Sunnah if it's not proper then you are
in fault to sinning yeah so and only
that is fumbling I won't worry as much
because all these boss I don't have not
been personally involved even though it
must have been made towards me etc
whatever it may be even with the younger
of stripes the younger husband came to
the speaker's corner you know and giving
Salam and next we trust the recitation
of yo one light is problems this is what
happens when you young and jealous
anyways let's carry on Sharma and watch
the video
we call it obvious innocence both the
brothers who say that working the
deformity whether they have miskeen you
know what doesn't it seem so he will off
the question is that can you know
someone covered say that voting is a
diversion the voting is a form of
worship because in us to do a lot for
etc and you know that you had opposed
also he said no you can't say ultimately
whether those people disabled to utility
rather be on the scheme now of course we
know that assertion study routine from
Allah Allah said in this category Rodya
but everybody is anything that Allah is
pleased with anything which Allah is
pleased with it can be an action or
speech internal or external
key point is anything of what is pleased
with which I drop things quick corporal
test on this for a second this is the
highest form of ignorance the highest
degree of ignorance but after this after
this please update versus video please
take a timer go on holiday okey go to
Mecca Medina
study Twelver come on camera again your
ignorance is so high that you're seeing
Allah lasses not that you bother
yeah and I love is enough go further so
basically according to you Baba [ __ ] was
sooner
exogenous or not share
it was a mean no wait [ __ ] chef Athena
scuttle is the most striking he senses
and watch it watch it one more time
before you worship obligation to vote
for the lesser of two evils in elections
in the West it is an obligation that the
Muslim vote for the list of evil or
harmful to the Muslims to be bad yeah
quaternion OPA failure from among the
whole Muslims and there is no problem in
this the attention
he said it's logic and here is evidence
that follows he backed this Sigma naught
with evidence from the Quran through a
room where there's wonderful in which
Allah tells the Muslims to realize that
the victory of Christians over the
Persian majid mediums or something about
show they music Allah has decided that
that that we be happy for their victory
that is about the Christian defeating
the Persians because then the Christians
were close to taste gun did you
understand that all should I take you
brother's words and say chef Hussein me
in the chef or sulla and all these
people check father shatori yes yes I
the Kshatriyas well actually yet
something that you respect are doing
that's of course on Allah but uh
modifies mostly mush of lines given our
verdict my brother
what likely is on your place this is the
signs that you need to sit back up your
camera we've seen anything that I was
pleased with and then I can be bad ok
good now you're coming from your
perspective and saying this is an act of
Cooper this is from your perspective
from you by the way who are you what's
your qualification badly notices really
lucky creep our question is are you only
the second thing is you see it as a form
anything that allows Jesus that I think
about it is really bad a scuffle my Baba
firstly you have no right to see the
statement anyway you have no
qualifications at all forget that for a
second when the ship comes and gets its
rulings is getting it from Allah and the
Sunnah he's deriving this understanding
you can't now let's say I do I've an
understanding yeah then utilize Ahmad
understand remote you Leslie looking at
AlcoholEdu one I follow and may see the
future we both get something this person
can go to the other and save your scene
you do active soldier Nevada isn't
accepted
neither can basic otherwise as opposite
way why because they both are
knowledgeable on the matter and it can
be a difference of opinion it is a
difference of opinion how could you come
and say that this method of Godiva is an
act of offer because if the action is
done for the sake of Allah then it's a
form of a bad it's a work of finger
things which you know for all we know
that we know that arise on please do
something that discuss the Haram or
Cooper but who are you to say that
working the act of offer who are you
because we've got a list of scholars so
u s-- important to see the situation in
general you'll agree is hara we know
that in specific situations of course
you can say the voting is a murder and I
agree 100% anyone who says that voting
isn't a bother
without a shadow of a donkey on the
scheme good so now what brother
unluckily doing these game prepared
because he's looking for the fault of
the ship and he thinks caught the [ __ ]
out inshallah someone's here mistaken
process and said for some time said
anybody who looks for the mistake of
another believer
allow find his mistake and humiliate him
in his very own house this is the reason
why Papa you are being humiliated random
in this video inshallah you know why
because you look for the mistake [ __ ]
mother this is my fashion assumption
even is not perfect it makes a lot of
mistakes I don't agree with them of
everything but when you go out there in
a disrespectful tone when you are the Oh
baby student want to name the baby
student knowledge you slide past one a
half year ago and you're looking for the
mistake of individuals I keep this is
what's going to happen now we're going
to find out with the real riskiness
because chef even he's talking about
when he's talking about divider the
enemies except divider is and I mean
voting is a form of advantage of this
scheme you know we're talking about
everything in our religion is about
everything
medium is videos of similarity matter
however we have sick Avada meaning these
conditions for example that are
confirmed by the Quran and Sunnah so the
southern
bazooka the fasting the hatch the
exceptional anything was mentioned by
check these are set in badges meaning
you can't play around with this you can
Thomas a hey I'm going to play five
rocket issue organism or Alden certainly
open a second this is wrong I don't want
to keep another where we get this from
the tape the analogy to a final card is
a firecracker issue
well somebody stays up with a fast from
floor tomorrow
hold on a second Bravo this is a advisor
yeah it's so creepy
so you who is telling you that you can
do this isn't harm until driven haha
this is simple this is what chefs
talking about but brother Abu Bakr
things we caught the shack slipping but
you know what actually happened it's
actually you're like understanding which
even embarrass yourself in a minute
let's go and find out I shall under the
rooms penis link a better
yeah this is part of our dad so I wanted
to hold it for a second I'm just one of
Abu Bakr's fix now bonuses when I put
this in the title the face you make when
you're ignorant on a massive contrast
due to a lack of knowledge I don't need
this above the bubble I genuinely
genuinely because you need a big step up
happy you made a big step up and that's
why I want to show you why this is an
act of ignorance because what he's done
now is this you have content and Ottoman
second ago you said if anyone who said
that this Amato voted a bada is in the
screen now you're looking the share with
that face by paying holder second now
you sing one thing give me better let me
tell you this much but like I said
before if you claim that this is one of
the set conditions that's it and divide
that in that state in the form anything
with Nevada well 15 is one of the
separate categories that we mentioned
literally seen however now you might
comment notice the question facing same
a Dada
because lava is I'm going to vote for
the sake of Allah for the lesser of the
two evils because one is causing a
greater harm them is on converter around
another that is a form of a bada if I'm
going to go east on food to be sure
to place a lot that is the form of a
vada if I'm going to go to the gym and
get strong for the sake of Allah
that is a form of divisor so she hatin
we see in the month of Ramadan what
you're doing if the person you vote for
is going to make the mass of the Muslims
easier not going to bomb our brothers
and sisters in a rocket land that is a
form of attack you know why because and
it's something that Allah loves how
because it's an action that you're
you're trying to decrease the heart and
increase the good now there is a
profound statement which I want to share
with you guys which all right so this is
a saying from a scholar our lives
profound are that Olga Faline and about
that of salihin what this means is that
the normal actions of the heedless
people like going to work financial
dealings contract etc are in fact acts
of verjus for the righteous people
because they do this action with
righteous intentions so for example a
non-muslim does voting he might be
voting because of is voting whatever it
may be
but when a Muslim doing is he saying oh
Allah doing this for your sake I'm doing
this for your sake so our balances are
not bombed so our life is made in so I
can worship you do you understand my
buffer that's why no offense you are
mocking the chef by having that face one
line you are the miss skinnier you are
the Miss skin you made a big slip up you
made a big step of an using scheme well
let's carry on
maybe he meant like any browser
linguistics technically oh I'm doing a
reading man oh well I won last the Akiba
may Allah bless you what line you don't
know you don't know a key what like you
making this video is a big mistake in
itself what lie you don't know
stick to what you know but if you
embarrass yourself with this by thinking
the chef's contradict himself but
instead you know why you know why you're
actually shocked a key because you can't
grasp the knowledge you can't grasp and
understand because you can't understand
you from the mother the other person the
forgiveness review above all you can't
understand and this is why you
embarrassed yourself another miss Kenya
that was a long car okay that there was
a contradiction okey you
thing is a contradiction because you
can't understand is that we go to
somebody and explaining to them they're
seen or Allah says in the Quran that you
he made humans out of collect human
beings out of clay and then the place he
says he made a mouth water
another thing says he made them out of
sperm you can say look contradictions
we're going to say buffer the problem is
with you you can't grasp it it's no
contribution is a country distinction
meaning Allah we are also we are made of
water we also made a spur we also made
of clay expert etc it's not contradict
as a country distinction the problem is
review Bravo don't blame the share one
like that's why they say a jar he'll
will never know who's a real scholar but
the scholar will know he's a guy because
the scholar was once a child so that's
what I see I don't blame my family what
you did their act is unreal the big clip
of Spinola you really embarrassed
yourself and this is an evidence to
stick to your leg nappies stick to lean
hard shoulder cause of my ignorance
maybe it's because of my young age maybe
these are facts revolted against these
if anyone is watching this and you have
the answers he's confident down below
well I bless you at least you asked you
said comment section below I thought
I'll do something better than a comment
maybe I haven't got time to read you to
watch this earlier and he his advice the
person Salman said the deal is that
light is my advice to each other now
let's move on to another issue okay so
what's the matter if there is a small
kid and he reads the Quran does it
become wrong course not it doesn't
matter if someone is young or old the
hawk is spoken it shouldn't be accepted
and this is our game now with this
statement the brothers what they're
trying to say is that we have permission
from chief Osceola that we can come and
talk about these matters hold on a
second book pause pause pause have a
little break here chef was soo Allah was
talking about a specific situation when
this molded issue has happened when
there was an issue about anemia where
this chef was so Allah say and he's
right if a kid comes with a Quran if
somebody comes with pork is actually a
lot I would say hold on a second even
though he comes Portis I didn't nobody's
denying that you are using this evidence
like it gives
the permission to go out and speak to
matters but over your head you're coming
out making it seem like this is given us
a full thing I challenge you buffer will
go to Medina will go to Mecca together
and will go to chef Joshua and will show
all the stuff that you guys have been
doing and talking about matters that's
over your head yeah and let's go and sit
down with the chef and say is this
permissible I am ready to do that I'm
ready to inshallah by the energy I'm
planning on going and I will go and see
chef for sulla myself I'm gonna go see
chef Asura with the brother and I'm
going to show the content I'm going to
say chef is this permissible is these
bubbles talking about FS giving giving a
general ruling getting the names of the
scholars in the books and applying on
the specific situation yeah it is
permissible not only that Moose's father
went decision was sulla in person him so
and in the picture and you're going to
be played right now and look what she
was you'll assent about this matter
let's see here brother what he said
missile era commander ahem I'm Adnan
Rashid I want to clarify that i met
sheikh was your la bus during the Hajj
2016 i had a meeting with him and I put
some problems in front of him and I told
him there are some young brothers in the
UK were using your name to attack other
scholars and I mentioned [ __ ] hate them
and hot dogs in particular and Sheikh
said he know he knows Sheikh item and he
said he knows good of him then I told
him of the brothers who are attacking
him young brothers with little knowledge
and and Sheikh was he loved was aware of
them he was actually aware of the
brothers he mentioned them by name and
he said if they are using my name to
attack of the scholars and they should
fear Allah and they should stop doing
what they're doing
so cher monsieur la bas did not agree
with this approach rather he criticized
it in front of me in person so I am at
non machines I am witness to the to the
fact that she was yo la criticized the
brothers who use his name to attack
other scholars so they should stop doing
it they should not use the sheiks name
and the picture can be seen where I met
the ship the evidence is clear Salam
alaikum a fella
where is everything a circle so Allah
said you can go and start future
scholars well again I love you more
handed for a little
but collectibles you have some lava a
corner now the reason why I put these
videos one after another and cutted them
this is another issue that we have we
already have the disease of young people
think talking about matters that over
their head that's another issue now we
have another problem the blob availab
listen I shall have memorized some for
some things in Arabic that he's
memorized a actually one life one life
is not one line is not hard to memorize
Arabic word it's not hard
listen video I put them all together you
see in words in Arabic language actively
it doesn't make you that one line if you
concentrated more on understanding
what's being said if you started with
different people and you understand it
the knowledge that you're being given
instead of concentrating on just Arabic
words that you can use on a video and
this might be wrong
yeah a lot of people are most talk was
talking about you a lot people go and
say these Arabic words and when a
supernova Wow martial arts such
knowledge of a key you Arabic words mean
nothing about Jahan do Arabic Abu jahil
you Arabic may be better than new but
his Abu jahil is a jargon within the
piste of the Hellfire it doesn't mean
nothing if you do not implement it and
don't stick in your lane baa baa
so using Arabic words this style of it
maybe it doesn't mean anything lucky one
way I can memorize Arabic word
understand that but I am approach the
reason why I don't do it oh I do do I
don't do in public I am a personal
reason inshallah when it'll are going to
uplift this oppression from us Petra
Carter do in the cold fact in your
religion may Allah bless the Baba this
is the point where I was the acting
mashallah if you did the video just on
this 100 staying with you
the ballast spot the hack when that
person speaks the hug you have to give
it to the guy the processbook part Allah
will humiliate us and I would the
brother until we turn back to his
religion brothers and sisters Allah will
keep humiliating us until we turn back
to Allah and his messenger we turn back
to the Quran and the Sunnah we will be
humiliated
all right the brothers rise in speaking
the truth speaking up until we turn back
to religion brother insisted so don't
think your numbers are you doing this or
you're doing that
understanding the true way of the Salaf
and following the Quran and Sunnah is
your victory
other than that do not see this anywhere
else stick to your lane you study in
mashallah carry on
stick to your lane brother I am a giant
I'm telling it in common I am a jar heal
I don't know I don't know I'm jolly if I
continue with these methods voting this
that better reject it from me say look
you are a nobody rejected for me
unsubscribe go to my channel and
unsubscribe click do not listen to me if
I ever come to you and sit on myself on
the table without a scholar do this but
I always come and speak these matters I
imagine power I talk about what I know I
don't know I don't know I said hello
saying I don't know is a part of
religion so bothering sister's sister
inshallah but due respect this is
opinion she has a boo sama sabi if I
express Francis name what he believes he
does a wonderful time to lock and if
somebody you should watch watches videos
somebody balance mashallah may Allah
bless him watch his videos in sha allah
may allah bless you assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi back'